erste prototypen die mit hilfe des
sogenannten nano floss l konzepts
angetrieben werden waren bereits auf den
straßen der schweiz diese elektroautos
werden nicht mit hilfe einer batterie
mit vielen zellen angetrieben sondern
durch zwei elektrolyt flüssigkeiten die
über eine membran elektrizität für den
elektromotor erzeugen die einen feiern
es die anderen zerreißen ist in der luft
doch was ist wirklich dran an diesem
hype ihr habt euch dieses thema beim az
gewünscht wie man übrigens dazu kommt
mehr am ende des videos und bekommt es
auch jetzt in klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen
die technik der fluss zellen batterie
ist nicht neu sondern schon seit mitte
des vergangenen jahrhunderts bekannt
es gab auch schon experimente bei der
nasa die diesen energiespeicher
konstruierte konkret geht es um eine art
redox flow batterie hier zirkulieren
sowohl ein elektrolyt mit positiver
ladung als auch ein elektrolyt mit
negativer ladung in zwei getrennten
kreisläufen durch eine membran findet 1
millionen austausch statt der dafür
sorgt dass die e motoren angetrieben
werden die vorteile liegen auf der hand
diese fahren der batterie ist
preisgünstig und ermöglicht zudem große
reichweiten in windkraft- und
solaranlagen werden +10 schon seit
einiger zeit zur stationären
energiespeicherung eingesetzt doch diese
konstruktion sind oft größer als mehrere
autos doch dieses problem will das
schweizerische unternehmen name floss
zell gelöst haben
das verfahren sei reif für den
serieneinsatz zitat mit der nano zell
haben wir es erstmals geschafft eine
fluss zelle auf die größe eines
aktenkoffers zu reduzieren und
gleichzeitig die energiedichte der
elektrolyte zu verzehnfachen
eine andere frau zählt ist der derzeit
innovativste und leistungsfähigste
energielieferant für mobile und
stationäre elektrische anwendungen die
beiden verschiedene geladenen letzten
flüssigkeiten werden in zwei separaten
tanks gespeichert heißt also anders als
bei herkömmlichen batterien können die
flüssigen elektrolyten außerhalb der
eigentlichen zelle gelagert werden das
wäre der absolute wahnsinn statt
stundenlang die eigene batterie zu laden
fährt man an eine tankstelle und tankt
geladene elektrolyt flüssigkeit
revolutioniert wäre das und das würde
nur ein paar minuten dauern im endeffekt
ist das auch der entscheidende
unterschied die gespeicherte
energiemenge ist nicht mehr von der
zellen größe abhängig energiewandler und
energiespeicher sind getrennt
voneinander
laut der offiziellen webseite ist die
energiemenge die bereitgestellt werden
kann abhängig von zwei faktoren zum
einen von der elektrolyt konzentration
in der elektrolyt flüssigkeit und vom
volumen der elektrolyt tanks beides
könne aber an die unterschiedlichen
anwendungen angepasst werden nerviges
und langes aufladen das gibt's nicht
mehr sobald er
mit flüssigkeiten verbraucht sind wird
nachgefüllt was bedeutet das konkret für
elektrofahrzeuge eine bedeutende rolle
spielt der filter der der verbrauchten
elektrolyt flüssigkeit die gelösten
salze m zieht durch einen generator der
durch die farbe energie angetrieben wird
wird das übrig gebliebene wasser zu
wasserdampf zerstäubt ab und an müssen
die elektrolyt tanks natürlich
aufgefüllt werden dazu heißt es auf der
website mit nanotechnologie könnten
allein im straßenverkehr jährlich 19
1250 meter tonnen co2 emissionen aus der
verbrennung fossiler brennstoffe
vermieden werden das sind 75 prozent der
weltweit durch transport und verkehrt
solchen co2 emissionen und die umwelt
und nachhaltigkeits bilanz der
produktion von name flow zählt sieht
auch ziemlich gut aus wenn man den
offiziellen angaben traut man verwende
rohstoffe die in großer menge verfügbar
sein
beziehungsweise umweltverträglich
gesundheits unbedenklich und nachhaltig
gefertigt werden metalle seltener erden
und metalle werden demnach nicht
eingesetzt doch entscheidend dem
themenbereich autos ist natürlich auch
die leistung der vorteil hier selbst
nach 10 tausend ladezyklen soll kein
memoryeffekt eintreten sagt dazu das
versprechen der hersteller das bedeutet
dass die nato zählt bis zu zehnmal mehr
ladevorgängen bewältigen kann als
konventionelle lithium-ionen-akku
systeme lithium-ionen-akku circa 1000
ladezyklen in einem automobil würde dies
einer reichweite von rund zehn millionen
kilometern entsprechen und damit die
lebensdauer eines modernen automobils
bei weitem übertreffen zusammengefasst
also noch einmal für alle die jetzt
ihren eigenen ohren nicht trauen konnten
eine reichweite von 1000 kilometern kein
problem
die nach tankzeit grund vier minuten die
batterie kaum altern mehr als 10.000
ladezyklen und ein beispiel aus der
praxis wurde auch geliefert mit dem
kleinwagen quandt tino der auf der 48
volt technik basiert und 2 159 liter
elektrolyt tanks hat sei man mit bis zu
80 kilometer pro stunde mehr als 14
stunden am stück gefahren also alles
viel zu schön um wahr zu sein oder lange
jahre pries die firma nano zell solche
sensationellen daten und leistung
werte an teilweise vergleichbar mit
supersportwagen auch die eigenen
studienergebnisse versprachen immer
wieder neue sensationen doch lange
dürfte niemand die sogenannten krank
autos fahren die prototypen mit
deutscher zulassung fahren nur auf den
straßen der schweiz den treibstoff und
den tankvorgang wie man nicht öffentlich
machen und die technischen daten
scheinen teilweise vor allem eines
unrealistisch und genau diese
geheimniskrämerei führte dann dazu dass
immer mehr zweifel an der
glaubwürdigkeit des unternehmens
aufgaben und das von allen seiten im
oktober 2016 dann die wende
die fachpresse war eingeladen zu einer
ersten probefahrt superkondensatoren die
als strom puffer zwischen der fluss
zelle und dem elektromotor geschaltet
sind sollen eine beschleunigung von rund
5 sekunden von 0 auf 100
stundenkilometer möglich machen
eigentlich nicht möglich für ein
fahrzeug mit einer masse von rund 1200
kilogramm in dem testbericht einer
großen auto zeitschrift auto motor und
sport vom 6 oktober 2016 hieß es dazu
zitat die versprochenen dynamik kann der
fluss 10 flow auf dem testgelände nicht
ganz beweisen aber trotzdem fährt er
typisch elektroauto ansatzlos zügig los
auch zwei prototypen der großen
automobilfirmen müssen bei der ersten
fahrt kann sich abstriche gemacht werden
immerhin der kantine absolviert seine
erste ausfahrt völlig problemlos er wird
zwar vernehmlich liegt aber und auf der
straße und wirkt überraschend solide ja
was die testfahrer also bestätigen
konnten waren eher grundsätzliche
erkenntnisse die fahrzeuge werden von
elektromotoren angetrieben und ihre
reichweite passt um einen ganzen
nachmittag zu fahren zudem waren die
fahrzeuge wohl gut und hochwertig
verarbeiteten abgesehen von der leistung
wie sieht die infrastruktur aus eher mau
es gibt noch keine einzige ladestation
doch der technikchef des unternehmens
nunzio la vecchia ist optimistisch da
die flüssigkeiten unbedenklich sein und
keine hochdruck tanz braucht seien
entsprechende tankstationen leicht zu
installieren zehn cent pro liter wurden
mal als preis angegeben ob das
tatsächlich realistisch ist halte ich
jedoch bei allem optimismus für fraglich
mittlerweile soll es weitere testfahrten
mit japanischen ingenieuren gegeben
haben wonach die autos ohne nachtanken
1000 kilometer fahren konnten fest steht
jedenfalls name float sein will gar
nicht unbedingt ein autohersteller sein
sondern sieht elektroautos nur als einen
teil dennoch wenn alles stimmt was das
unternehmen behauptet könnte die zukunft
der e autos wirklich bezahlbar sauber
und nachhaltig sein und eines ist
wichtig immer wieder gibt es scharlatane
die mit absurden ideen leichtgläubige
investoren über den tisch ziehen aber es
gibt auch revolutionäre technik die
jahrelang von behörden und
alteingesessenen unternehmen blockiert
wird ja immer ja nur an den brennwert
kessel der einen viel höheren
wirkungsgrad als normale als heizkessel
hat die abgase waren sogar kalt kein
ingenieur wollte das glauben und dem
erfinder wurden noch und noch steine in
den weg gelegt heute ist der
brennwertkessel fast in jedem haus
befinden weil die technik einfach viel
besser ist als die alte heizkessel
technik es könnte also wirklich
funktionieren ich bin jedenfalls extrem
gespannt und wenn ihr immer als erstes
neues zum thema elektroautos und zu
allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
meldet euch hierbei whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen von mir
vom neuesten video direkt wenn es
hochgeladen wurde garantiert ihr könnt
dort direkt in der redaktion von giggs
und mitmachen und mir themen vorschlagen
oder über abstimmungen mitbestimmen
einfach draufklicken und natürlich nicht
das aber mit der glocke vergessen hier
geht es weiter mit dafür auch darauf
klicken bald nur noch elektroautos
technik vor technologiesprung da geht es
um eine andere innovation ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran